[Music]
planets
they are home to super storms they're
home to oceans of magma
and in earth's case they're home to life
some of humanity's greatest thinkers
have dedicated their lives to studying
these awesome places
hi i'm rich burnett for one dream and in
this episode of perspectives we're going
to hear from a handful of scientists
they're going to share their favorite
facts about planets in our solar system
and beyond we're going to begin our
journey on mercury
as we learn about just how difficult it
is to match its trajectory
as it speeds around the sun enjoy
we studied earth from space and compared
our planet with all the other worlds in
our solar system
all of these missions together have made
it possible
to assemble what can be called a field
guide to the planets
and other bodies in our solar system we
now know
vicariously from our spacecraft a great
deal about what it is like
to visit these worlds
mercury is a planet of extremes it's the
smallest planet in the solar system and
the closest planet to the sun
it travels around the sun much faster
than any other planet
60 percent faster than earth at average
speeds of over 100
000 miles per hour even getting into
orbit around mercury is unusually
challenging that's because spacecraft as
well as comets or
anything else speed up as they get
closer to the sun
the force of gravity causes everything
to speed up as it approaches the sun
and moves deeper into what we call the
sun's gravity well
similarly objects falling to the surface
of the earth speed up as they get deeper
in earth's gravity well
so if you want to send a spacecraft to
mercury the big issue
is slowing down the next planet in our
solar system
is venus venus is also a rocky planet
but unlike mercury venus has a thick
atmosphere
of carbon dioxide which blankets the
surface and causes it to heat up
to over 850 degrees fahrenheit
it's an exaggerated version of the
greenhouse effect that we're concerned
about here on the earth
venus also has clouds made of sulfuric
acid
so even though the ancient greeks and
romans saw venus as the goddess of
love with all that fire and brimstone
it's
really more like the traditional concept
of hell
there's no clear-cut answer to where
earth ends
and space begins but there are ways we
can define
boundaries between earth and the rest of
the solar system
it could be based on the altitude at
which the atmosphere is so sparse that
it no longer behaves like a gas
that's called the thermopause or
where the earth's magnetic field no
longer shields us from the solar wind
that's the magnetopause in terms of
gravity
the boundary might be the distance from
earth where the sun's gravity
is stronger than the earth's gravity
that's about
1.5 million kilometers from earth at the
boundary of its gravitational hill
sphere
but this definition would make the moon
part of earth
and not in space which is not how we
think of it
governments and other organizations have
tried to define a particular altitude
above earth's surface
known as the carmen line that signals
the beginning of outer space
but of course they don't all agree on
the specific altitude
of the carmen line the united states for
example
uses 80 kilometers it's set a little
higher
at 100 kilometers by the world body
governing air sports
the federation international
earth is our only frame of reference for
a habitable planet
but even here we find life forms
surviving and
thriving in shockingly harsh conditions
we've discovered organisms that breathe
sulfur and bacteria that can survive
extreme gravity
or live a half mile deep in an antarctic
lake
eyeless creatures live out their entire
lives in pitch dark
caves and microscopic creatures known as
tardigrades
have even survived exposures to the
vacuum of space
but despite all these differences the
one
universal need of all living things on
earth
is liquid water water is therefore seen
as a non-negotiable requirement for
supporting life
sci-fi going all the way back to h.g
wells has focused on scenarios where
alien creatures from mars destroy life
on earth
but mars might have very fragile and
primitive life
incapable of withstanding microbes from
earth
we might be far more deadly to any
actual martians than they are to us
fortunately planetary protection officer
is a job at nasa
in fact there's an entire office of
planetary protection
the office works to ensure spacecraft
are as sterile as possible
when we send them to mars and other
planets because we don't want to
contaminate them
the planetary protection office also
makes sure flight plans prevent
spacecraft from colliding with
unintended planetary bodies
and of course they also ensure we don't
contaminate the earth with
extraterrestrial life when we bring back
samples from other planets
jupiter at five times the earth's sun
distance orbits the sun every
12 earth years even so the jupiter day
is short
only about 10 hours because jupiter
rotates on its axis
really fast that rapid rotation causes
the planet to bulge
about its middle and you can see that
phenomenon in photographs of the planet
and it also causes really extreme
weather
that's because the circumference of
jupiter at the equator is more than
430 000 kilometers
so the atmosphere at the equator has to
travel about 43 000 kilometers per hour
relative to the atmosphere at the poles
and as a consequence
the fast rotation breaks jupiter's thick
atmosphere into fast-moving bands and
swirls which are easily seen as a
sequence of lighter
and darker stripes parallel to jupiter's
equator
jupiter also experiences extreme wind
shearing that creates
immense vortices cyclones many times the
diameter of earth that can last for many
years
with sustained winds of hundreds of
kilometers per hour
for unusual features at the poles
nothing compares to saturn
to begin with at the south pole is a
vortex
that's a giant eye of a hurricane you
can peer
right down into the hurricane this thing
is 8
000 kilometers across it's two-thirds
the size of earth
and it's ringed by tower and clouds the
winds travel clockwise at speeds of more
than 500 kilometers an hour
another strange strange feature is up at
the north
pole of saturn here the atmospheric flow
takes the shape of a hexagon
and this was a huge puzzle for
scientists until some people modeled it
as a particular jet stream of gas
moving at different speeds than the
surrounding atmosphere
and this causes the flow to break up
into
six separate little eddies little swirls
if the differences in speed were
different this could have been an
octagon or a decagon
or some other shape the outermost
planets uranus and neptune
are often called ice giants because they
are primarily composed of ices
they each have vastly more water locked
away than is found in earth
but it's important to realize that ice
in planetary science
is much broader than frozen water ice
the category called ices refers not only
to water
but also to ammonia methane and other
materials that are volatile
because they have low temperatures for
melting and evaporation
moreover while these ice materials might
be solid
they can also be liquid or gaseous the
word ice or icy
just refers to the composition of the
material
beginning in the 1780s william and
caroline herschel
began to build a systematic catalogue of
the northern night sky
for wide publication the brother sister
team
constructed telescopes together and used
them from their home in england
to painstakingly improve on past stellar
catalogs
sweeping their telescopes methodically
across the sky
and making note of both known and newly
discovered objects
the catalog became an invaluable part of
the scientific literature
listing object's positions sizes and
brightnesses
and considered how they might be
classified
their observations also turned up
numerous new objects
william discovered the planet uranus
while caroline discovered numerous
comments
her work was recognized with the gold
medal from the royal astronomical
society
an honor that wouldn't be given to a
woman again until vera rubin received it
for her work on dark matter in 1996.
the herschel's final result the new
general catalog
is still used today and many famous
astronomical objects
are identified by their ngc number
neptune's axis tilt is similar to
earth's and so the planet experiences
seasons
unfortunately for neptune watchers the
year on neptune
is 165 earth years long
that means that all the data we have
about neptune's atmosphere
whether from voyager 2 or earth-based
telescopes
is less than a quarter of a year
so the only seasonal change we've seen
on neptune so far
is the southern hemisphere change from
spring to summer
the astronomical heroes or maybe
anti-heroes
behind pluto's journey from discovery to
demotion
span more than 70 years in 1930
clyde tombaugh discovered pluto and
classified it as the ninth planet in our
solar system
in 1960 julio fernandez predicted that
an enormous and crowded belt
of small rocky objects should surround
the outside of our solar system
just at and beyond pluto's orbit
in 1992 david jewett and jane liu
discovered the first observational
evidence of this belt
the research that followed ultimately
led to pluto's demotion from planet
status in 2006
along with a significantly expanded
picture of
our solar system and its outer
boundaries
discoveries of exoplanets have
demonstrated that planets around other
stars are abundant and varied
gas giant planets orbiting extremely
close to their parent stars
called hot jupiters were the first to be
discovered
but they actually make up the minority
of exoplanets that are out there
smaller worlds are more abundant and
there's a variety
not seen in our solar system there are
rocky planets many times bigger than
earth
aptly named super earths some of these
super earths may also contain a large
fraction of water
up to about 50 percent making them more
like water worlds than
rocky worlds and there are lava worlds
rocky planets so close to their stars
that they are covered in global magma
oceans
in the coming years we are facing a
burst of incredible innovation in
astronomy
tomorrow's heroes of astronomy are hard
at work today
working on new telescopes that have been
decades in the making
and laying the groundwork for
astonishing new discoveries
that will continue to change how we see
the universe
thanks for watching if you'd like to
learn more about any of the topics in
this episode
the full list of series that these clips
came from is in the description below
you can watch all the full series now on
onedream.com and don't forget to
subscribe to this youtube channel
turn on notifications and you'll get an
alert every time we post a new episode
of perspectives